I'm thinking about dr. strange I was
like it doesn't look like he has any
powers that I can like mimic you know
like when I want to be Iron Man I go
Captain America I throw a shield
Oh Thor have a hammer okay dr. strange
what I do like it yeah
kind of what magneto does hey I want to
be one of those superheroes we just hold
out her hand and what's the visual
effects Department
but the struggle Sestito strangers here
you Scottish from I understand is a lot
line system a little blogging citizen
Benedick cucumbers back this time is
joining Marvel let's do this doctor
strings strings his hands hands this
what makes it special just training
doctors really anyway you think you know
how the world works
what if I told you oh the reality you
know is one of many
whoa this doesn't make any sense not
ever who does magic man not everything
has to it's good explanation
three domestic cars with harness energy
and shape reality
we travel great distances
so I get from here to there
how did you become a doctor studying
practice your Spanish same thing
there's a strength to him that is he
ready
I'll be ready
I'll be ready I don't think it's a the
temple which path to travel downstream
stronger men than you but away
oh [ __ ]
okay
we pay
the diaper tectal this world
there's no other way
Jesus Oh
oh my goodness
whoa
is that New York City
what's this I'm not sure the Wi-Fi
password huh
we're not savages
Wow my favorite part was the Wi-Fi
password oh yeah I'm totally logged in
from yeah how do you change my password
to that now sure you know how many
people are gonna do that a lot of
people's things are gonna get real
hackable risk benedict cumberbatch
american accent very sexy my friend yeah
very sexy I'm a fan of your work
a Benedict I would like you to talk to
me in that accident sometime when a lot
of people do an American accent it it
almost makes him sound nerdier but
Benedict Cumberbatch sounds even deeper
and more sexy and cooking yeah yeah
totally
Benedict Cumberbatch is perfectly cast
for this role it serves a like an actor
who can really adjust to John rrah I
feel like Benedict Cumberbatch is one of
the best he really knows how to blend
into like any kind of John rather is he
still believes the world and believes
everything that's going on yeah it seems
like he really invests himself in every
character he plays since like no matter
where he shows up he's gonna do with the
road John yeah and this looks really
cool like this looks really inventive
and yeah visually it likes is very very
appealing here's my concern though I
feel like this movie might hold back cuz
I'm one of those people in real life who
does believe in like energy and all that
kind of stuff and that energy being
physical I don't believe I'm capable of
doing such things at least yet yet you
guys study in practice uh-huh it's like
being a doctor what I'm a little worried
about is that this could be one of those
films that could be really deep very
philosophical could even be like you
know semi matrix level you know I have a
feeling though that they're they might
hold back and kind of conform to some
marble conventionality case Oh Doctor
Strange gets injured he goes meets the
ancient one gets trained Mads Mikkelsen
sits comes in and then is like oh I'm
evil and then dr. strange has to take
him down that's kind of what it looks
like it's gonna play out us but I feel
like there's a lot to explore here Alex
matrix is one of my all-time favorite
movies Inception is another film that a
lot of people are referencing when they
look at this
well yeah and it does sort of have a
tone that's kind of no like I thought
about inception during this true at
least in the way that it handles its
tone cuz inception still a blockbuster
but it has you know these strange looks
so very attentive and very creative and
very different yeah and and this could
be the genre marbles looking to crash
into next and and I like the the two
guys who wrote it see Robert Cargill who
used to write for a Nakul and who used
to be on spill comm is a critic like he
co-wrote sinister with scott derrickson
another co-writing and directing this I
think those guys do cool stuff he's the
guy did um Emily Rose Jim well as much
as they can do cool stuff you know
Marvel it does sort of have a reputation
though for like kind of the committing
certain creativity even though their
films are very creative sometimes they
hold that the a director some how far
they can go and that's what means like I
feel like this film can go [ __ ]
batshit crazy with it's like
philosophies yeah 10 you know it's
spiritual pass and all that stuff ok
what's also really cool is a Doctor
Strange this meets Benedict Cumberbatch
and this character looks like he has a
lot of like purpose a lot of meaning I
really feel like there's a lot of depth
to this character not it might be just
because Benedict Cumberbatch is an
intense [ __ ] actor but this guy
really seems like he's Purpose Driven he
was the doctor hands got injured and
he's like that's this thing is being the
surgeon and now he's like on this quest
to like you know turn his life around
cuz I imagine that once he gets in that
accident he probably feels like his
whole world is crushed he depends so
much funny you see his hands the doctor
yeah and then he's gonna uncover
something bigger here and you know
ancient one sounds like she's been
waiting for strange show up oh been like
hey I know you've been coming here
strange I can tell time I can travel the
world I could do anything I could even
stop this bad guy but I'm not going to
I'm going to teach you how to do a lot
of people are gonna die along the way
but it'll be worth it because you'll
have some kickass powers this movie does
look like it has a certain amount of
kick-ass this like it kind of has a
almost fantastical scope to it too which
is a nice facet explore the magic this
time like Marvel hasn't touched the
magical territory yet I mean like on the
psychedelic you know the strange the
strange you know and and I feel like
they have all the tools and and your
worry is the same worry
I have four this is like I feel like now
there were two point especially with
these choices they're making with their
new phase it seems like they could go
that deep with everything it doesn't
seem like it would hurt them not to get
you know like Anna Marvel honestly like
any time I have a concern I rarely come
out of the movie like that was my exact
concern and yeah that's what happened
that worry is not that usually well yeah
or it's you know there's some times
where you're like yeah I was kind of
worried about that but it's not like a
huge issue in this movie there are
things about ant-man that I was kind of
worried about that were kind of what I
was expecting but the movie was better
than I thought you know I hope they go
all in with this cuz they've got you
know a great cast and a cool team and it
looks like they dumped a lot of money in
the effects this is an opportunity to do
so much and I hope they take it I really
also hope that they write Rachel McAdams
as character interesting yes a character
they easily not be interesting you got
to do that like Natalie Portman when she
was in Thor she's good in the first or
second Thoreau's whatever but I don't
know they poor my Khan doesn't give a
[ __ ] about these MCU films I kind of
wish she was out of her contract Rachel
McAdams is a very talented actress and
very cool and I feel like that may be
the first movie they might not need oh
really give her that much screen time
because Doctor Strange sounds like he's
going to be away from her waters moving
but hopefully you know like it at least
alludes to a bigger character or more
I'm sure if you comic book fans know
like something magical happens with her
down the road or something yeah she gets
pregnant but still would Vietnamese
children it's easy to underwrite a
doctor Strange's really vietnamese
american vietnamese this was Benedict
Cumberbatch's point strange isn't it yes
America made me is duper strange how
would you feel if I told you my surgeon
who's gonna do my open-heart surgery is
Vietnamese American you're gonna be like
I don't know about that
but if you saw was Benedict Cumberbatch
where am I going with this
I don't know well guys comic-con keeps
delivering if you're new sub scribe
reasons to Jerry he is also the social
media manager of bloom house.com
Facebook page go there type stuff
running out the clock here before the
camera cuts we ran out the clock it's
like a basketball game this is what Kobe
is what Kobe does up ahead and Laker
game
damn going up against the I don't know
Chicago Bulls Michael Jordan's math
throwing three-pointer Kobe jumps up
blocks the shot Oh Kobe's better than my
control